Oh no, God.
oh my god
my phone
hold on
eating the microphone to my mouth hole
okay my microphone is at the end of the door
mumahinha
guys I have a mummy deficient so yeah I don't know
if I can make it
now you're gonna make it with me
hang in there
it's not too cold at all
good morning good evening good afternoon
can you hear these beats in the background
that's from the video game that we're about to play
thank you Jacob
oaks cause we're becoming a member
and dot gar for becoming a member as well
my good morning good evening good afternoon
did you see Mercy's new role play
did you listen to me cut my hair in it for her
yeah cut my hair from the Mercy role play that's right
that's right I sacrificed my little hair strands
in the name of doing hair cutting ASMR
I was actually here cutting
it was a certified classic Mercy role play
it was a fantastic role play
um look I might be a little bit biased
on the Mercy role play okay
I may or may not have been the one who wrote it
I am a little bit biased okay
listen to it when I fell asleep in someone
oh you enjoyed it I'm glad
someone was bald now no I cut my fringe like my bangs
but it was overgrown
like horrifically overgrown
it kind of worked out in the end
your bangs your precious bangs my cabbages
I'm a loby belly bald
she loves her thank you Jacob
oh there's no way I'm going to say that right
thanks for the extended membership
right updates
my updates are
um
I can't stream too long for today
however I have fantastic reasoning as to why
the veiler video game
finishing touches are occurring today
so I don't know how long this game is going to last
but turnip boy took like 3 hours
turnip boy tax evasion was 3 hours
um
make me choose between you and Mercy to be my veiler
oh she'll make it Mercy
Mercy tries very hard
I am not a jealous streamer
I just want you to be happy
I want you to enjoy who you enjoy
no stress no this no that okay
it's about 5 hours oh shhh
shhh
um right
hmm
it's about 5 hours to play
did you end up re-recording your part of the game
no so what's happening is
I am shipping off everyone else's sections
and then I am having to redo my lines
because I need to completely redo my section
my last scene thankfully the rest of my lines are fine
my only worry is that it was so long ago
that it's going to be rather clear that I've recorded it
at two different times but it is what it is
it was my first experience ever
dealing with video game type stuff
production wise so you know let me fuck up
thankfully none of the girls have any messed up sections
or anything wrong
but the finishing touches
it's all going to be packaged away today
and then we are waiting to see the fruits of our labour
will the game be on steam
no it will not be on steam it will be on itch.io
it will be free to play you don't have to pay any money
to access it or anything of that nature
the girls were most likely to play it on the blue site
although they'd be rather embarrassed when it comes to their section
but let them be embarrassed
but yes that is the
finishing touches are getting done today
which I can't avoid or stall any longer
because it's already been delayed so much
just due to issues with
you know I messed up in a few sections
areas of the game
embarrassment equals good
so if you
we're not here there is a game called turnip boy
commits tax evasion
and it was a hoot and a holler I loved it I adored it
I didn't know what to expect so I said
alright we're going to play the sequel
so this does kanone kalei
it does come
off a
after what events have happened
it says rob's a bank I don't know what to expect
I didn't look off anything so we're going to find out
you see that turnip with a pistol he's literally me
it's so good that you can see the dead boss
from the previous game
kanone kalei
breaking news release of indy title causes 22,700
reflinks to dissolve in the dust after inking too much
I messed it up
it was supposed to be banal but it's hot dog
and unfortunately it is what it is
I mean I think it's still hot either way
turnip boy how do you
I'm going to give you a badminton for that
yeah ok there you go
well it doesn't feel bad
as I said it was the first time
I learned to do something like that
and you know with the success of vlo
it's not like it's a one and done
and we'll never try and pursue something of that nature ever again
so don't write us off just yet
don't write us off just yet
don't be like oh that was really disappointing bro it's the first time I've ever done something
give me some skin
give me some of that goodness
do you know when the game is going to get released
no so the final touches are being everything
is being packaged off today so the ball
is no longer in my core after today
that is why I don't have too much time to
cut about today on stream
and I hope that that's ok
I do have fantastic news
for the girls
their next emote batch is beginning
AC is first up on the commission
for her emote batches
if I recall correctly
it's between 7 and 10 emotes but everyone's going to get new emote batches soon
how much sleep did you get
I actually did alright
I woke up an hour early before stream
to record the kissing audio that we wrote together
in a membership stream but my phone
my phone
was like 6% battery
and I was like I'm not risking recording this
and like running out of the script
how much is alright in hours
I think 7
I really wasn't that bad but
you'll be flooded by Maros
wait with what
is it going to be a game with different routes
no so there's
one main thing you do
the replayability factor
is if you like that feeling of a completionist type
angle completely up to you
if you want to do that you don't have to do it
did you drink water today
but did you pray today
flooded by Maros I think
7 is good we'll take 7
yeah that was bad
one main thing you do
basically I demand uni
I mean there will be different routes
if you didn't know Ozzy is flying for routes
means shagging
7 is better than 4
at least you aren't going back to no sleep
as I said there is now a third editor
in play I have good news for the reflins
we might have 3 audios
for the subscriber series
like one video per one case
there might be 3 audios
and more on the way
so as I said reflins were eating good
the girls have been doing fantastic
they've been keeping up with their audios
we're just at this stage of where I want them to be
a month, 2 months in advance type thing
Azura's donathon got finalised
she was a great sport
working through different problems
coming together to agreements
but I've got a bit of background work
to enable Azura to deliver
the donathon as fast as possible
because I am aware other agencies
have struggled with the delivery time
and it's completely understandable
because there's a lot of things that come together
but thankfully because Veilure
is so both equally hands off
and equally hands on if necessary
I can basically say do this, this, this, this
and then you've done all of this in advance
before it's not like she'll do the donathon
and then she's just completely on her own
she gets zero help, there's, you know
oh no, this is you, you agree to this
that's you, you made that money, you deal with it
no, it's not like that at all
it's like right here's a script, you do that
the team will edit it and upload it as soon
and then we can mark that off the list and move on to the next thing
what we're talking about, Azura's donathon
I'm putting a lot of things
in place to very quickly
blast through her goals
so we're just doing a lot of things in advance
to enable her to prepare her
to do it
and you're all across it
did you see the sauna artwork?
I've been sitting on that artwork for months
for literal months
I have been sitting on that artwork
I'm so glad it finally came to light
now I did say to the girls, I said to them
look, I've not ordered anything beyond this point
in terms of celebration artwork
there's a 5k celebration artwork
the sauna is the 10k celebration artwork
and those white hips
you can definitely see that Mercy's definitely got a bigger chest
than me naturally in that artwork
I told the girls, I've not ordered any group stuff beyond that
but if you want me to
I am more than happy to celebrate
the group artworks like that
because it's so cute
I like all of us together
I thoroughly enjoy artwork
where we're all together
as I said I did order an artwork
personal artwork, which I'll share
but don't ruin the surprise
it's a secret
but I do have a wee doodly artwork
on the way of all six of us
hi, inking!
I love the sauna artwork
them hips gonna make me go wild
it was very nice to commission that
I thoroughly enjoyed putting everyone as the focus
and then I'm just kind of lurking in the background
I'm so unsure around the girls
which is probably the complete opposite
I'm the pervert that runs around
because I was talking to Shibi in DMs
and I spoiler a message
and you know what I fucking said
I'm gonna get in trouble for this
I went nice but by the way
I'm like oh my god
I'm gonna get in trouble for this shit
I can't be seeing this shit
what the fuck
you look adorable and nervous
very cute
a grip kissing artwork
give me a slumber party artwork
maybe for 15k
you get my daughters to 15k
slumber party artwork is yours
and that's that Strony Golem artwork
no worries you're the HR
Strony's thoughts and the damn I'm flat
damn I'm hype
did you see my goth artwork as well
wink wink it's not our work
I just messed around with my Vtube studio
and I made myself look like a god
does Vehler have a sexual harassment policy from boys
absolutely not
nope they have to
in the interview I specified that they have to
tolerate all sexual harassment from me
no I did not
no but we don't have a HR
or anything like that
that's not how it works around here
we ain't working like that
okay
because no one in the development team
has access to the girls and vice versa
the only people who can be harassed
is me
to them
I said what I said and I stand on it
not gonna lie goth Vehler looks like
well it's gone
I was trying to read it but I couldn't make it
you just look really well in black goth stuff
goth Strony's lovely the goth doesn't fit you well
I'm glad you don't think so
I once snuck into a girls slumber party
it wasn't with her promise
goth mummy for genti
oh you just want me to pop up in genti as well
oh it's going
I'm not Strony calls I'm goth McGee
alright you got me
you got me
I'm convinced you don't say anything
okay I've got a cup of tea that's why I'm stalling
mummy I've got a tummy ache
oh no what did you eat
you eat something bad
every gen actually secretly
has a hidden Strony
real and true
well you're already all six Vehler girls
so why not another six
exactly
right it's AC snowfall time
I'm watching Yu-Gi-Oh
oh wait that's not how AC sounds
Ajii-san
I'm watching Yu-Gi-Oh
wait how would she say it in her accent
Privites
I'm watching Yu-Gi-Oh
Yu-Gi-Oh
no there's no way
Strony goth being all of the gents
real and true
I have canned french onion soup
I can't
did you heat it up right
normally canned food is fine
it's always the french
literally
hold on let me check if there's any marshmallows
cause I'm gonna drink
I really wish she wouldn't do that
I really really wish she wouldn't do that
that could have gone terribly wrong
I'm not gonna lie
you could have seen links to stuff
if you didn't catch that
OBS started to capture what
was on my youtube
on my browsing thing
and it could have shown marshmallow links
to certain things
that aren't supposed to be shared
hi Strony
this is absolutely real and true
okay gospel truth
I now seem to have a mental block
where I can't ink to anything at all
I was laying in bed last night
my tentacle decided it wanted attention
I did
so I thought
I'd just
look something up on my phone
and get out of my system
nothing was doing anything
all the things I'm normally into
I'm not interested
I had to download twitter on my phone
and sign in so I could listen to an odd
your audio
and when I heard you I was finally able to
I'm mind broken you
but I'm not even done it yet
I said before that I was mind broken
but I meant it in the way that I was mainly
interested in what you're making
I'm only interested in
inking to you
my brain will only let me ink to you
take responsibility
mommy
reflet oh no
you've been corrupted
oh my gosh
Strony please for the love of everything
if you get a goth outfit
get a runny makeup toggle
oh you want a runny makeup toggle
stream ideal example for you
and it's a cat box link
oh my god I'm going to open up a cat box link
I swear to god if I'm getting pranked by a pintus
oh right
oh no no no
I understand I've seen that feature before
he did it
Strony life goes to be honest
it's not makeup
she just has ink dripping down her face
hmm
will there be a discord server at some point
for reflance to speak
unfortunately no
yeah
for the safety
of myself and all talents
there's no
velour
speakable discord
there is a notification discord
if you want to keep up with shorts
if you want to keep up with streams
videos
because there's a lot of things that get pushed out
even if you hit that cheeky
notification bell
youtube will still not push out
the key intent
running makeup
you better go catch it
thank you
I'll be here
sometimes I'm glad I met you
I'm glad I met you too reflin
hi Strony
hi reflin
god you look so adorable in the bathtub
you look so cute and lovable and nervous
I want to hug you forever
you look amazing
and the goth recolour too
it fits you super well
black is always your colour
someone sent me the most sussiest link of all
that I've never even seen in my life
nope as if I'm clicking that
nice try
it seems mummy ain't just got the eyes to hypnotise
it's your whole deal that makes you a blessed meal
are you winning
we ain't even started yet
I'm trying to drink my tea
so it's still hot
not room temperature
but we are about to start playing in a moment
but yes lots of interesting things for the girls
we've got emotes coming out soon
we have a collab coming out in someone else's channel
the ball is now in their court
thank fucking god
cause I hate the ball being in my court
it annoys me
I've got a collab coming out with a vtuber
Sun Tiem
as always Sun Tiem with me
hey mummy
maybe bad thing to say
but did the collab this week go through
it's getting rescheduled
it's been rescheduled
Katarina is having me on the
the 8th for the rest of the world
the 9th for Aussies
all of September
it had to get rescheduled
cause there was a few issues with timing
but yes Katarina is having me on her channel next month
not this month
it was a reschedule issue
that we came across
and then together we defeated the rescheduling issue
by destroying it into smithereens
and now we were the winners of that
hi strongy
just a little feedback
you seem really quiet recently
yes the microphone has not been in my mouth
the microphone is right next to my mouth
I'm kissing the microphone
I probably sound so clear
compared to other streams
unfortunately I've been a lazy bum
and not been sucking the microphone off
hi
sorry for you to enter
as soon as I said that sentence
I need goth mummy to blackmail me
I need you to step on me
oh I never commissioned that artwork actually
I'm going for gore
oooh
speaking of donathon
what exactly is yours and how long will it go on for
we're going to discuss it in the membership stream
but no leaks
no leaks
we're going to discuss what the plan is for me
cause I
I am a bit different in terms of donathons
I don't mind speaking about this
so most donathons are like personal
it's like moving out
you know security money
because this kind of job doesn't last forever
if you want to call it a job
personally I don't fuck if this is a job
fuck I'm fucking shitting
huffing to you right now I'm writing scripts
I'm having fun I'm collabing
yeah job job
yeah yeah wink wink nudge nudge
oh I feel so overworked
no
mine are related to
advancing other people
in terms of
confirmation that gen 2 production occurs
does that mean there's a
confirmation date when gen 2 come out
no it just means that production is confirmed
production is
one very expensive
two takes a lot of time
as I said I was pregnant with the girls for a year
it took me an entire year of
pregnancy
with gen 1
but my donathon goes
you know I've already got everything I need
basically
you know I got my reflins
so mine are like
reward reward reward
public reward more more more content more more more
you know
hospital bills are insane nowadays
honestly for plopping
yeah plopping them all empty
yes
for how long my donathon is going to go on for
so Azura is just 12 hours
because she's you know hers is to move out
and she can't stream for like 40 hours in a row
up next is Shibi
and now I'm going to ask her if she wants to do
48 hours she doesn't have to do 48 hours
but if she wants to she can
I might do the 48 hours type
bang as well
yes
and basically I was going to play
Assassin's Creed Brotherhood through my whole
donathon
I know cringe
but I love Assassin's Creed Brotherhood
favourite game of all time
and it just makes me a happy little bean
when is Azura's donathon
so Azura's birthday is the 21st
of August
however her donathon is on Saturday
a 12 hour donathon on the 24th
Saturday 12 hours she's playing
she is starting her donathon
at the
time I see usually starts
I'm going to try and do it in your time zones
without having to actually name a time zone
and we are going to be showing up on her channel
and doing a collab
but some of the girls might be streaming on that day as well
but everyone will be redirecting back into Azura
so please don't do your thing
don't worry don't worry I'll plan it out
there's a trailer currently
advertisement trailer currently being made for Azura
I'm very curious how it's going to come out
very curious
I'm making a trailer
and then I can attach it
and then we can put some googly ads behind it
I'm going to be the first to kind of put ads behind it
stream trailer before
because it never really
for debut
things were really strange for debut
because the youtube accounts were so new
it was hard to get anything fricking confirmed properly
it was really awkward
but I do try very hard
hey strony lovin be alert so far
I had a crazy dream of puppies
strony with their collar and leash
panting harder than Azura's
ahegyo toggle
you can't waning and begging for my ink
you've corrupted me
stay corrupted see what happens
hey
hi hi reflins
but young
lots of goody goody stuff
as I said now that a third editor is in play
my
my responsibilities are getting close to zero
like seriously
if the girls want an ASMR script
I write it that's about it
that's probably as close as we're getting now
to the point where I'm not even doing anything
so feels good man
and I can do
tons of rewards
and I can focus on my ASMR stuff
cause I got loads of collabs that are waiting on me
it's just a long awaited sequel
to mummy commits tax fraud exactly
this comes right after tax fraud
let me finish his teeth
and now work on gen 2
well gen 2 I don't work on it actively
because I'm not like the creator of the designs
I'm not the one making the ref sheets
I'm not the one making the lures
I'm basically the one that goes
here's the money do this please
that's my job when it comes to gen 2
I'm like here's the money please take
and the person goes yes I have taken the money
thank you
what kind of tea you're drinking honey tea
I use it for my voice box
whether or not it actually helps
as a whole other kettle of fish
alright are we ready to
let's go it only took me 26 minutes
of yapping to start
oh my god classic woman
tell me if I need to lore raise
dedicated to toast the queen
of fort fat ass
oh and the we thing passed away
two days after killing a god
okay this is instantly after the tax thing
draws an athona
one day after the civil war the broker
as a result
my phone's gonna
mushy mushy
hey hey is this a bad time
oh wait what's the new york
hey I'm walking here
is this a bad time
I got a job for you
a big one
come meet me if you want the deets
where am I
my general direction is
right yeah just walk right
blink
beep beep beep beep beep beep
beep beep beep beep
I'm trying so hard it's so hard
hi momay your voices are really sizzling
hmm
up on your feet touring your
head we've got business to
discuss
you're probably wondering why I called
you here
the twin
chinos owned by your father
dawn and the pickled
gang have been fighting forever
I don't break traditions
easily kid and I
can see in your red
beady unchanging
eyes that you don't trust me
so just hear me out
toilet pet
ever since you've defeated that ego maniac
mayor onion veggie bill
has fallen to ruin
there's war in fighting
tax fraud
there's only one thing
to do with a toy like this
and that's to use the opportunity
to make some money
your resume
of killing a god
and arguably the bravest thing you've done
commit tax evasion
makes you the perfect touring
for the job
we need you fighting skills on this one
if you're gonna rob the biggest
oh if we're gonna rob
the biggest bank in the world
what do you say kid
family tradition
who cares about that nonsense
let's just
make that bag and get rich
you know what do you say
do you want to follow
in your father's footsteps
take a job you didn't
ask for
or do you want to make a name for yourself
turn of head
what I would do
the next morning
excuse me
is the burp stuck in my throat
oh there it was
oh there
that one is like really stuck
alright toynoped
robbing a bank
serious business
I'm glad you decided
to work with the pickle game
but I run a tight ship here
so I ain't gonna tolerate
no incompetence
we gotta train you
up proper
or we're all gonna end up sleeping with the fishes
so learn how to use
them stubby legs of yours
and come talk to me when you
ready to shape up
capiche
rafael's part robot now
it comes with perks
oh rafael's part robot now
rafael now has
portable gem made from
own robot bones
train hard boy
turnip you will need it
okay
uh
hi turnip boy
surprised to see me here
hmm
yeah dillentini broke me into this
he's giving me way better funding
than mayor onion one
somehow his scientists are always
working for the mom
ooh were you a pokeball
twin one
I can't believe after all
these years we're working with the turnip
you know the son of the dawn
no less
you better keep yourself on your toes
we're watching you
we'll be in
press A to talk to
dillentini
you want to know how to
extract some dope from the locals
eh
you want to wake them
you want to walk up to these dummies
and shake them down
why are you giving the hag a lolly
or is it a hag oops
you're gonna walk up to these dummies and shake
them down make them
rain they are riches
walk up to three dummies
and shake them down with A
shakey shakey shakey like a party animal
rickety rickety rickety like a party animal
beef a piata
filled with
word on the street is twin number
two shoved a piece in a dummy
go beat the crap out of it
and grab it
pick up the weapon
oh yeah
shoot the two dummies with right trigger
oh
you got to get used to
your full kit toy in your head
get a feel for switching up your weapons
you may need to switch it up
on the fly while we're in there
how do I switch
that's a gun
oh
you remember how you landed on your
feces last night
wow it really starts with that one
how you landed on your face last night
you know how you
tripped in a dirt like a sap
it might come in handy
when dodging the fuzz bullets
and getting past them lasers
we gotta test you
on it though
twin two hit the lasers
what
no
trip through the laser with left trigger
you did great
term see tripping through those lasers
like a pro what
you think the botanical
bank is gonna rob itself
forget about it
get in the truck
we got work to do
in the truck in the truck in the truck
you got a glock
we were already doing it
what is this
a turnip with a gun
daring to break into my beautiful
establishment on this fine day
not just any turnip
the son of the old dawn
turnip chino in the flesh
turnip boy about to pull up on the block
and let that point four zero bank
literally I'm strapped
and it's been like two minutes into the game
a thank you to be a lord for the super chat
I see you're trying to live up to that
fool's legacy
I wonder what he would think about you working
with that low life pickle
it's cute
that you think you can just waltz
in here and mess with me and my crew
I'm can't give him the same voice
you've got gumption
what the fuck is gumption
I'll give you that but that ain't gonna hold up
in here
you got the fuzz wrapped around my little garlic
chin air
just gotta hit one button and make the call
I don't know what voice to give him
fuck it make him a governor
wooshish you jammed the airwaves
you're in a world of hurt now
turnip you better be ready
when the jammer timer goes off
the fuzz will be swarming when that timer
beeps its last pop
remember my name turnip
stinky
the bank manager that's gonna put you behind bars
now make like a banana
and get out of here
oh god what am I doing
I got an achievement
gimme
gimme your fucking money
gimme your
fuck it this is a stick up
this is a stick up gimme your money
gimme it all
this is what I think about your fancy feng shui
get out of here
this is the start let me just
oh this is a hag
the intel I've gathered
says that stinky has allowed
these artisans in here to
spruce up the place
as food folks
seem to be going through our
renaissance era
the old world so well
so exciting
this is a stick up
gimme your goddamn money
oh shit
gimme the money gimme
gimme the goddamn money
I need it more than you
easy there robber
I'm standing here
oh you think you can just walk around here
all willy-nilly oh sticky
wants to put in a new wall
but all we have are these wimpy
statues I ain't moving them
so if you're trying to get through them
you gotta break them good thing you don't have a pickaxe
who are you
hello on this painting
yeah it's the famous streamer
her name is slay queen 32
wait you know her
she commissioned me for the painting
she's going to have it in
her background for her
street setup I'm a huge thimp
I will say though
she's been a little quiet ever since
I started finalizing the design
do you think you could talk to her about payment
I get a little nervous wait why is everyone
hanging out in the bank and you know her so
it might be easy for you to do it if you wouldn't mind
he's a sim gem
thank you so much your lifesaver
$100 reduced
she be getting here
where
ah
I just got walloped
sorry
this is the control
I'm very slippery right now
I kid you not the controls are so slippery
ow
god how do I survive
what are you
I'm running out of voices
accent German
how do you like my property
I think it's very nice
and cosy
okay
oh I've got 2 minutes left
what's this
it's a new boy
I've been studying the floor plans
of the botanical plant I've learned that these elevators are special
see these elevators lead to completely random rooms
wait as you tour
it seems like that the bank security system
is wired to swap them out
whenever someone breaks in
I think there means
we're going to have to rob this place
several times to get the full picture
so grab what you need to escape in the truck
and then get this place to reshuffle
what the fuck does that mean
give me the money
from milk to eminem
this is very
wiggly swiggly this time around
like this
I know you can't really tell
but it's very wiggly
French
I have used
bleh
thank you bleh and refling senpai
for the extended membership
I'm very slip like refling's pills
that's an interesting way to secure a bank
I don't understand
French
I used to be a
big flipping
young individual like yourself
now I stand here protecting these elevators
with my life
that's what I'm trained to do
I dabble in tourism as well
come back to me if you want little facts about these rooms
turnip head
based on our intel you can't trip over unstable blue lasers
there has to be
there has to be a circuit
wait no wrong
oh I am walking here
there has to be a circuit box
you can't break to shut them off
shut them off
stop it
random
why
wee
ah
we're getting money though
oh there's shitting me
ah
there actually hurting me
wah
wee
now we can see what's beyond
the unstable blue lasers
this seems easy maybe too easy
step on it turnip head
step on it where
am I to go back to the truck
I'll go back to the truck don't think I won
I'm going back to the truck
I'm going back to the truck I'm scared
please put me through the elevator shaft
direct I knew this wouldn't be
easy
we've got to blow this vault to smithereens
we may need to express
order some c4
on the dark web or do it when you
get back to the warehouse
okay hell on earth
I get down I'm stuck
oh here elevator shaft
ah ah ah ah
I'm going I'm going I'm going
back to the truck I'm going back to the truck
hello c4 please
oh yeah
we made
a lot of money
and mommy just means sorry
oh
alright
rookie let me give you the
lowdown come on over here
you pulling in rookie
numbers rookie
we've got to sweep every inch of this
being
being stuck in that pickle jar
as long as we had
been really
really changes your perspective on things
toynip head we learn
the valuable lesson
that lesson being sometimes
you need to steal to get
what you want
this is the last big job
toynip head stinky
has the vaults of all the
what stinky has the vaults
of all the vaults somewhere on the botanical
being
we have to
find the
mystery wait what in the
runescape doubling money
is this text
we have to find
the mysterious mother load
to make this whole
thing worth it to be
able to put all of this behind
us go deeper and see
what you can find
uh
ash hi eternal boy
come here for a second
I've got something that should come in handy
okay hi
welcome to my new lab
Dilettini gave
me a good deal for getting you guys
on the dark web on the computer over there
so make sure you buy
anything you need from it
from what Dilettini
has told me we'll be using
your money to pay
for these things
yes Dilettini
says we've got a tight budget
go check out the dark web
and see if there's anything that can be
of use c4 c4
oh oh no we
can't afford
well we can afford the c4
purchase an eye almost in dark web
okay we can
now
wait there's another thing I need to do
yeah I can't afford that
task completo
why does the avocado
you don't want to shag the avocado what's going on
you know she's got a big seed
in the middle right
it just
works okay
so what I'll go back into the bank
oh they're gone actually
walking here Robo Raphael
keeps saying we're making financial
gains when we should be making
physical ones
I suppose it doesn't matter more money for us
when we totally absolutely for sure
split the end profits
we'll be making the real gains
when we find stinky
secret stash we need to
get deeper into the bank voice
make sure you're talking to the locals
to get the scoop on what's happening
and don't forget to go on the dark web
if you need anything to brute force
your way in okay they're telling me
about the minecraft pickaxe
hello
hello boy turnip
wait is that my robot voice
Raphael now Robo
Raphael cheated death
I have bigger gains learned how to
spell name life is good
come back later for performance
enhancers
goodbye boy turnip
okay uh so we just
go back in again
oh we do
it's just a stick up mother fucker
oh wait so I just like shake
them every time I come in here
curious
okay right uh
no
okay so they just vending machines
drop money as well sometimes
depending on the circumstance
don't you show me stop it
you're scaring me
don't be selfish
she be spank
she be getting a spank guards getting a spank
right the pickaxe I can't progress
shake it shake it shake it look like a party animal
ricka ricka ricka look like a party animal
okay
oh
okay we're gonna see for
blow up that vault we found this way
okay so
I guess we have the same
oh
sorry that scared me that genuinely scared me
okay we can't go past blue that's
illegal
um so I guess
we just constantly keep coming back to the bank
what's this
I'm not picking up a freaking captive
oh
jeez wasn't paying attention
ow ow ow ow ow ow ow
she be
she be you're getting me killed here I'm getting embarrassed okay
okay so
right we keep coming
give me the money
so we keep coming back to the bank which is
I've got me out
oh hey bud look
scram you're gonna get me in trouble
where's that stupid melon anyways
okay okay fine since you're so
noisy I was gonna meet a co-worker
of mine a melon slice in one of the vaults
but it seems like he got lost I have a
package I ain't got
package
so you repeatedly robbing the same
well I found a rare artifact
man I hate Mondays it's Garfunkel
bring a rare artifact to big
melon slice
I don't know how
what are you
what are you a beat
question mark
cease communication with me now
earthling vegetable
oh jeez well excuse me
some of us
gorking
wait so
it gets randomized and things aren't in the same
location every time
I cannot tell you how slippery this is
blow that vault door up with the
see
floor and all that
dough will be my I mean Alice
that fool
stinky won't even know what's gonna hit
him
oh my gosh
okay it seems like
the maximum amount of money I can carry is a thousand at a time
so we might as well just go back that's
done
it's payday
so the second is more
rogue light is that the
oh wait sorry the elevator was back here
the lift
was the lift back here yes it is
yes so it seems like
randomized maps
which actually I'm done
with okay that's so slippery though
I don't know why
money money money
can I afford the minecraft pickaxe
I can't afford the minecraft pickaxe
okay we're gonna get it
poichnips
Italian
I am at the auditorium
me poichnips I'm all set up
come over here
who are you you
hello Tom she could have you to stop by
as you know by now my brother and I
are notorious weapons dealers
we supply for all
catastrophes of life
for wars or raids
highs do you name it we cover it
I'm currently setting up shop
come back and see that selection later
me
me I'm still here
listen poichnips
fuck I can't do this
this is terrible as I can't do that many accent
I see all the torridor friends
listen poichnips we got
the means of making new weaponery
now I'm all set up alright
let me put in this way
all you gotta do is bring me some of those
crummy weapons you'll find in a bank
and I'll make better ones
go check out my blueprint
board to see the genius behind it
wow
primord okay
you're just rushing now primord guns
from your enemies cold dead hands
and give them to me for science of course
yes
ah tom she great timing
come here
hello my friend I am now you're on
and ready gun dealer
you want to change your loadout
check out my weapon
a rack it is most beautiful
kind of a rack there is no better
no better yes the best rack
hello tom she grab
your guns
task
complete though okay let us
get let us get
minecraft pickies
here we go we have pickies
look turnip boy I'm helping out
for the finding
for the funding but there's a lot
of secrets within the bank
as the brains
of this operation and having an
insatiable need to quench my
curiosity I want
to try and uncover these secrets
I have a feeling that this
isn't just a bank
most of this structure is from
the all the world stinky
has just been building onto it
why is he here
what is his plan
I need to catalog anything
that you think is strange
just snap a photo
on your phone as photo spots
an album app will appear on
your phone so you can look at what
you've captured we'll correct
the code to this bank in no time
what a unique
part 2
right so
okay
um
what a fantastic little
experience the next one show any
11 photos
I've got 11 photos of something all right
right I'll do a bird's eye view of it
I'll do an under view of it
I'll do a POV suck view of it
hahahaha
turnip boy stays literally
ret app
ed
okay I write oh yeah how's
your broken wing thrown it it's much better
it's like tender
but if I don't touch it then I
genuinely am like not even aware
whoa
oh wait sorry
right we definitely
have a thousand
dollar redo limit
so I'm guessing that is
definitely an upgrade
bomb head acquired
stop it you're scaring me
stop it it's turning me on
it's not really
can I have this please
hahahaha
hello
uh
so basically what you're saying is
this is oh I never even saw him
oh my gosh they're giving me a fright I'm like not
paying attention
so what you're saying is this is actually
just the binding of Isaac
wait how do I equip the
I have a bank
hey robot
I see why old stinky wanted me to
put this in here with a crappy wall it was
to block you thanks much you don't
have a pickaxe anything we'd be in
real trouble yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay you're lucky I forgot to equip
the pickaxe it's over for you
eh
right okay
let's explore
we're
explore
ow I literally just tanked
that bullet in my face
what's this stat you
oh I just pressed A on it
oh we can
Minecraft
we can play Minecraft on those
Minecraft things
Chan from work right now
don't get in trouble
or do I encourage
no I don't encourage it stop it
I can mine this
I am remaining
what
wait so
we got actual Minecraft
for real for real
Imma break these wait I'm going back to those
original blocks I thought I had to equip
the thing but I guess not
I'm in the cave you're in the cave
looking for diamonds
I'm in the cave doing the same thing
but looking for
ah
right stop it okay new kind of
new area unlocked
whoa why are you angry don't be angry
I promise I'm good sometimes
not all the time
but sometimes oh
oh we've got a minute left I think we're gonna have to go back
swipe a card
I need someone's credit card
mmm I'm just gonna
stinky
the game called me stinky I'm not stinky
I'm
I'm just I'm pheromone maxing
boy turn up big boss
up ahead be prepared
nope nope nope
nope nope nope nope nope
okay I'm gonna run away with my monies
and my fishy to see
what this guy wants to do with my fishy
money money money
oh we were so shy
of 2001 but
they were blocking you
hold on they were blocking me
hello boy turn up
it's performance enhancer time come here
okay performance enhancer time
boy turn up robo roids
set up now
make boy turn up big
strong go look
meh
here use my card to open the door
stop momo that's good
here use my card
to open the door Brian
you're not supposed to say it
time to get ride rage boo
get off the stage
hydration check
so now that we have $2,000 reduced
what I do with it
whoa okay yummy
performance enhancers in my tummy
oh sorry yummy
gamer
10% use code strongy for 10%
off gamer subs link in the description
it helps you help us get a waifu cup
just let you should know
if you use the code we might get a cup
okay
and uh
someone very personal might be designing
the cup and I think you'll be very happy
like and subscribe
oh yeah like and subscribe
as well while you're at it
right gamer
cups
gamer subs
increase distance of boy turn ups
trip
increases maximum health
maximum health
okay okay
fill the gun faster
increases the money you can hold
okay yes this
we
it jumps up to 12.5k
oh no
adds an additional
timer minute oh that's a good one
bagged milk
what in the Canada a Canadian
apologies
split
spill
gotta let them know use code
use code strongy
for 10% off
as she said no we're not
let's say that in the contract
other things steroids inject
and billets billets do more damage
granola bars
pool
it's just merchant dice
well Rafael that's so cute
right we'll do heart
it's 5k
trip distance and then we can't
actually afford anything else I wonder
what our maximum amount to bring back
is
we'll check the dark with
laser pointer unfortunately
we don't have enough of laser pointers
so we're gonna see if we can do that boss
fight now that was like top left
right we're gonna shake them
we'll just shake everyone
literally they're getting robbed every day
those poor people
they must be so traumatized
I can't get in
get in
right we need to get rid of all the guards and stuff
cause they will shoot me
and then we'll go top left
yeah you
that's literally what
top left left left left left
top left top left
stop it
first boss fight let's see what we're looking at
shhhh
I don't know my voice to give um
oh yeehaw
well I'm napping here intruder
you're so causing trouble I'll have to
slice you up into turnip fries
yeehaw
uh uh
you asked for it
time to fry me some turnips
alright tour
alright turnip head
you defeated a god you can defeat this
chump easy
you're the one turning up army
mostly because I don't want to do it
myself and my team is doing their team
things important stuff you get it kid
it takes a crew to run a ship
turning up you're the cannons
this chump seems a bit
frayed around the edges
go finish him
yeehaw
a miracle
monster
ahhhh
nope it's not happening
oh my god
uh
okay
uh huh uh huh
okay uh huh hold on I need to
actually try hard
okay they are dropping hearts
yeehaw all stinky is how it is
to keep this here bank
in it's secret safe
get em boys
I love me some
those troops don't believe me
the goblins are real
what are you talking about
ah
I'm getting bullets
I'm walloping them
I've seen things turning up these goblins
trying to slice and fry me up
and serve me on a name letter
okay
all right cowboy I'm giving you one last shot
to surrender here so you drop your gun
and stick your hands up
wait we don't have hands
nevermind get em boys
woohoo
I need
I need those guys to drop my heart
it's not money
heart
drop a heart
have a heart
drop a heart are you serious
I'm actually gonna die right at the end of the dang fight
ahhhh
please drop a heart
please
no
okay
I farted my money away
you have to rule
of course I have to rule
I forgot about the mechanic
right
so I've lost me fishy
wait so then
if I want to start upgrading
upgrade
upgrading like health
it's 5k for health
sure I'll put luck in it
okay we're just gonna go on a money trip
straddling boys
we're going on a money trip
we're just gonna go straight for money
because I want to get tons of enhancers
I think once I got all the enhancements like this game
it becomes easy belem squeeze
funk
that's right I know you're there
I know you're there
shakey shakey shakey
this is a very cute game I like it
I don't know if you guys have played it
but I'm tempted to say
I recommend
although it's quite a reading simulator
I know maybe not like
all
strommers would like
voice it all and stuff
are you squidding me right now
10 months of being a reflanding ward
not only tax evasion
but taking what isn't ours as well
it's the best games
I can't believe I completely forgot
about the dodge mechanic
stop
I don't know if my controller
slightly bugged
not to be dramatic
or blame it on anything
but I haven't feeling my controller
it's a little bit bugged
because it's like acting so weird
I have reverence
get I'm strong these guys
got nothing on you
I got a mobile phone
someone's phone that's a very nice
oh wait does the gold
crates have a chance to drop money
hmm
right so that person
is always going to be done this hallway
surely it's the controller
it's not slippery I'm not kidding
that's why I keep saying oh it's so slippery
and no I'm not just saying that because ha ha
refling ink ha ha ha ha
no like genuinely it's a slip and slide
like I'm trying to aim a bit
but I'm not sure if there's like
the lair or something
we're gonna see how much our maximum
amount is for the bag
get that bag
we're at 1400
1.5
we're at 1.5
so
1.6 is never a maximum
I've got men alive they're going men alive
I've got other good first aid kits on the wall
I don't even know that
okay the enemy seems to
drop money too
okay okay we're going on
fill money run fill money run fill money run
I'm in the minecraft
playing minecraft
main main main main main main
do you... does your controller
have TOEFL addresses?
is that a thing?
we're at 1.8
thousand dollars
okay I'm going to quickly go back
for the truck because I don't want to be left behind
don't leave me behind
please mr truck
I'm coming
I'm coming I'm coming
is that faster to do that
okay we made it
we made
a lot of money
3.5
yay
we're getting rich off of this bank
thank god they're too dumb to
get stronger
GG
gun
trip maximum health not yet
I don't even use the gun
bullets do more damage
an additional minute
on the timer
maybe
increased melee damage seems like the best
cause I'm always whacking sure I'll buy the merch
new hat available
aww
we got some dosh we got some real dosh
so there's nothing new a laser pointer
I'll buy it cause I assume it's
for something later but
oh no that pickled banana
uh hey
uh yeah um
that avocado said they'd give
me money if I just stayed in the star filled
with green goop
it's not too bad I do feel a little tingly
though
I don't know how long I'm supposed to be in here
or how I'm getting out wait
have I been kidnapped
I mean
yes
oh wait who
was it you that randomly upgrades
my weird weapon
are you sure you want to swap wait
who was it is it you that upgrades the fish
research a weapon
I researched
a fidget
and then what I need to equip
my weapon
oh this is such a thingy
uh
refling POV
don't give me ideas since I joined them
I'm just trying to reason
you just got rid of the fishy I lost my fishy
give me my fishy back
I said give me my fishy back
okay so next
upgrade I will do
we'll get money again on this round and then I'll upgrade
health and then I'm going against that
stinky bank manager again cause we can
100% get that cowboy
that cowboy don't stand a chance
against someone like me
oh sorry let me shake this
watermelon
what a minute
remember that time I never got a watermelon in suica
game and that's literally the only objective
in that game is to get that
and I never got it cause I
I actually wanted
I saw a vtuber highlight video
and it was like vtubers react to their first time
getting a watermelon and I'm like
I'm raging cause obviously
I never got a watermelon and now it makes me want
to go for a watermelon
I don't know if maybe I should do an endurance stream
and I don't go offline until I get
the watermelon
but I don't know if that's a terrible idea
but we could do it
we could do endurance stream don't go offline until
what a minute
okay we're getting quite
a lot of things
40 hour endurance stream inbound
real and true
ow
I'm stuck on the box
jeez I'm getting walloped this round
this is why I want more health
jeez
oh he burps
little boobies
endurance stream into warm-up gets on the first try
I doubt it I was like really
struggling but I would be
down for those like cana silly endurance streams
where it's like it's not impossible
and it is a wee bit of luck
I'm not really sure how much skill
is involved
there's not really much up here
I'm breaking everything
oh wait
I'm going to take the cactus so I can research
the cactus
I'm going to research this cactus so hard
okay let's do this
the bomb almost seems like a good bet
40 hour endurance in the heavenly
okay
guys we're down I'll do it
right we need to go back to the
trip in a moment
is this a shotgun
it is a shotgun
not bad
oh my god I love the
shotgun
oh my god it doesn't have
much spread but I guess if I keep
researching the weapon
it'll be nicer to me
right okay let's get it
let's get rare here
lackluster
yap into
watermelon
oh I got
an achievement steal a total of
10,000 us dollars
well us turnip dollars or something
like that
right so research
my shotgun
I'm going to unlock an
oozie
right and then we don't have enough
for health we need one more
heist for health
okay one more heist for health
and then we're going to defeat that stinky boss
shan I can watch you 24-7
you are far too thin
oh no I only have a gun
I don't think my gun is very
strong
no my gun requires two shots
oh dear
this will be interesting
I just start
anyway I start blasting
okay yeah that's
what I was worried about
that I'm going to like I have to
actually aim and stuff yeah it's
shocking I don't want to have to aim
but I'm going to have to
wait I can't
I can't
because I can't smash the ATMs
in the money forum
give me
uh
I have one big
sometimes big oversight
sometimes maybe she sometimes
I guess we can destroy the stat use
we will destroy the stat use
and then
pray that I've got enough
I think it was like
30,400 so what
I need 1.6
and then
I have enough
thank you
Ruto Kawakami
I'm so sorry I think I'm like 100% sure
I forgot to say your name
thank you tea
wait they have health
what
you could be
I'm walking here
hey office workers
these chumps will never know the adrenaline
of the true crime lifestyle
maybe we can bring some excitement into
their lives they tone up head
see if there's anything else of value
here cupies
ah
wait so I've unlocked like I knew
you come prepare tone up head
that laser pointer should make quick
work of that shape
stop
okay
others have some rather satisfying
oh my
yeah I need my melee back
like no I'm too used to melee
can I have auto aim oh my god give me inbot
imagine if inbot was the thing in this game
hey man you wouldn't have to have a spare
spare HDR 90 30 widget
my boss took my old GPU
and I desperately need to
mine more
big dumb coin
can you maybe track them down sure
I'll do your quiz
shake down
alright we're already like out of time
for this area
I like okay we definitely
we're gonna upgrade
things and stuff
I don't know maybe I can like
very quickly shake someone down
up here maybe
unless the ATM machines do break
oh they do right I just need to keep shooting
I can't believe they didn't instantly break
after like the first five seconds
go away
right I can't do the boss
I'm gonna run out of time
surely I have enough
like um
tourist things
what are they called those items
to make up the difference
okay there you go
okay that's more than enough to get the next
upgrade for health okay we're going against
the big baddie the big meanie
the big stinkerton can I please equip
my dying sword again thanks that'd be great
love that lovely thank you
give me health please
increases max health the next one's that
20k juice
I like how he's just always smiling
shake you guys down because we just need a few
we did just spend a lot of money
okay we did spend a lot of money
okay thank you
oh there's like a hidden item there
okay uh what was it
up to the left up to the left
alright let's try this again
uh yee ho I'm
napping here intruder you start
causing trouble I'll have to slash
you up in a turn of fry
oh you asked for a time
to fry me some turnips
the sergeant
yee ho
bonk
okay
and then I just need to help him out with the
chair thingy my bobber
I plant
okay okay okay okay okay
all stink is harder to keep this here
man going to take her thing
they dickered him
they dickered abes
can I not hit him down
am I
am I being dumb can I not hit him down
oh no he comes down in a minute
oh sorry
na na na na
na
nope
okay okay hold on hold on hold on
I'm actually aim bottom right now
I'm like try harding I'm try harding
right he's gonna jump up and he's gonna do
this stupid laser thing
alright cowboy I'm giving you one last shot just a
right door here so you drop your good
and stick your hands up wait
we don't have any hands
never mind
right how to
what
okay wait I didn't even need to knock him down
okay
I need monies to drop health instead
of money that'd be great
I need
I'm trying
I'm trying sorry I'm trying hard
we have this in the bag if I don't mess up
is that bacon as in
I'm flying
come on come on come on come on
come on
come on come
come
and we came defeat the rabbit hole defeat
yee ha
I need my last
hot oh we got cars
the game just said congratulations
allows you to open
green doors
labeled with the number one
no way
new dark web listing
as well I have a
sniper rifle
what's that say
graffiti guys doing a vandalism
we'll look up to him now
okay we got four
okay so that's how you get fours
so what now we can enter here
oh why is this so dark
and spooky
oh well there's definitely something going
on at this bank
you've bested my sheriff
I may need to renegotiate
that fools contract
oh turn it boy I see
you've found my greatest failure
I've been trying to eradicate
these freeloaders out of my bank
but they insist that this is their new society
the seed stock
isn't that ludicrous
they always insist on using
alliteration
I see why onion wanted to tax
the crap out of them
I built the ground they walk on
you better make
like a tree and split
if you know what's good for you
you won't be here too long
you've got the fuzz in my arson
or watch yourself turn it
hey what is this
it looks like the old
veggieville townies have set up shop here
after your little
exploration in government
takeover and war
a lot of them didn't have many places to go
there must have almost been here
alright rookie
just try talking to them
to get the scoop
explore around a little bit
kill things that are in your way
the usual
the tan smoker here
oh it's that macaroni
eh he
ooh a treasure box
ok I may have to head back I'm getting very low health
I don't know if I can continue
very very low health indeed
I wonder
oh hello carrot
oh yes a new visitor
I've been waiting for
someone new to join my movement
for a while now
it's been so long since I've seen a new face
ew what's that
you don't have yourself a cardboard box
I'm afraid
I can't let you in without one
my sweet child
and once you have opened your mind
body and soul and acceptance
of our rectangular overlords
I will allow you to pass
you
shall not
pass
ok
woah that was worth so much
maybe I misread that
ok
I finally got health so at least I'm not
absolutely perishing
there is
so much to do in this game
yeah there's definitely
no way I'm able to wrap this up in 2 hours
like zero freaking chance
zero chance for wrapping this up in 2 hours
where did I come from
where did you come from where did you go
where did you come from
right we're going to head back to the trick
but yeah so far loving this
did I not kill him on the way in
that's like the first time I've never not
killed him
secret endurance stream
no no no I've got to do the video game
I have to do the video game
5000 in one house
we could probably get an upgrade
I'll see what's on the dark web
oh wait sorry can you research this item please
research
I've unlocked an SMG
no
no freaking way
wait hold on I don't want
oh but it's so weak
but it sprays more
um
the cardboard box to progress
$8000
Joffrey
Geofury
top rated seller at 69 ratings
you're extortionate
how dare you
absolutely extortionate unbelievable
you're unbelievable
I think my tummy ache is gone thank you
I pumped your stomach for you you're welcome
we can get the rain out
inflation is crazy
uh right
we will do a quick haze
um
wait
how am I selecting this so terribly wrong
right that one
make it right there we go
we'll do one more haze very quickly and get that
cardboard box
this is a stick up
uh yeah see like
they can tolerate quite a lot of the bullets
but
um
but I can spray them down before they even have time
to react to be fair it's
causing a lot more destruction
which
might be good
right we'll get our little cardboard
box for freaking a billion dollar
reviews
oh as if he survived that
right okay as a left
oh wait no we need
we don't have the cardboard box yet so we don't need
to go left yet
can you upgrade weapons yes
most likely
no these are all mp2
um
can't get in without that car yet okay so we
don't need to do anything on that side
of the map is the boss room
got anything to scavenge
or is it just empty now
look I'll look partner contract
look I'm set my contract says I gotta
finish fight you at least one time
only once other than
that I'm naffin if you provoke
me again I'll go kitty mode
turn try me turn it
right okay so you can
you can replay
sorry I thought I actually did not boss fight
so you can replay if you so desire
but I don't desire I just want
to get mula
we've got all up here in New York
yeah
well get ready for the suica
right singy then
the music is really good in this game as well
okay we'll main this get the cardboard
box go back to the carrot and see what the deal
is over on that part
from around these parts I'm from around
these parts
so far I
I think maybe stream wise
this game is a bit difficult to stream
but like if if I was
just being chilling on my own
and with my
thoughts I think I'd like enjoy
just like tuning out and playing this game a bit
mindlessly I don't know
if that's like controversial oh I got
my shotgun again out out out I'm getting
stuck out she
that keeps happening to me
why does this
happen to me
okay so the shotgun
kills them in one which is what I want to
see
the sheriff's room had a green door
at the very north of it
I didn't pay attention
okay all right now we
can break into this one
by the cardboard box say hello to the carrot
no sugar this is
the wrong one I keep going the wrong way
if there's only one shakedown oh wait no
oh it's this
one more bomba
go go have a good one starting recently
thank you for hanging
anyway I thought
it's blessed
okay it does have a reload timer
I mean that makes sense because
you know shotguns
oh no
oh
I've never forgotten the time before
whoopsies
that's the first time I've ever forgotten the time
I'm scared
go away Mr. Bacon
oh no
okay
that was a
that was a mistakey-wakey on my part
we didn't realize
Astroni having a whiskers in attention
fancy
so literally I'm gone
right we need cardboard box
give me cardboard box
and then
upgrade weapon
we just
unlocked a shotgun as well
stop
we'll be shotguns
what are you
seems like multiple
right we'll go with the carrot
we'll go
but first we shake them up
cause we need any moulas for upgrades
I like how the snails
like are dressed up from the last game
they're like dressed up
honestly
props to the dev team I'm loving them
absolutely loving them
shake them
snake
leave me alone
I'm just an innocent little turnip
I ain't hurt nobody I promise
sometimes
okay let's go let's go let's go
Mr. Carrot
Mr. Carrot I have the cardboard box
please let me into your
your exclusive club
it made me sad when you said I'm not allowed in your exclusive club
but now I'm in your now
sorry there's like oh my goodness
oh how many are you
hello
why is there so many enemies
got enemies
got a lot of enemies
please don't hit me with your baton
did we make it
okay
hi
oh my
that is a spectacular
cardboard box you have
there indeed it is
oh I most certainly can
let you in now
cardboard box collector
what the heck is that
you're new
monkey
why
these are shagging me
I'm not sure I want in your exclusive
club anymore what the heck
I can't even enter
I literally can't even enter
alright I'm running away so then
they have to come this way
are you squiddling me right now
the heck is this
best channel and my favorite
love you strongy no one is catching me at work
while watching her
you're safe for now
I guess
I'm just like unlocked a turnip with and thank you reverse for this
super chat
you're not in trouble for watching me at work
for now
okay I'm just trying to
very quickly go through and see what's
like up ahead I definitely need
the more time thing because
like
well that looks like a boss fight to me
so let me just back my
arse up real quick because I'm not doing a
boss fight with 40 seconds left
on the map I know I'm no I'm no
that's no one
that's no one I'm not doing it
I'm not doing a 40 second boss fight
you can argue amongst yourselves
where am I
oh they have extraction points
oh they're so smart
so you don't have to go all the way
back
not the not quality
of life
not quality of life enhancement
off the bat
what a fantastic dev team
quality of life off the bat
you don't have to backtrack
all the way
and you pay a little fee for it
who what a polish
game
dev teams instantly thinking
of quality of life stuff
bathwater
wait is that sleigh queens
I think it is
new favourite strongy game series
bell delphine
did you hear about that
she never even got the money for it
because PayPal shut her account down
she like made no money from it
because PayPal stole all
that's why you never hold your money in PayPal
it's rather insane
really
oh let's research
this bomb bar
okay and then let's equip
the shawty
yes I took a little sip a little hydration
right I'm just gonna check
that increases luck increases distance
trip
faster cool
apologies when
spilled no point in crying over
assuming maybe defense there's something
the bullets do more damage I think we're gonna have to
oh I want timer though
okay damage and timer
that's gonna help us with quality of life
great
oh she's got a question on her head
stinky seems to have
pretty bad reputation here
there have been a lot of
refugees coming to the botanical
bay
for shelter after the war
it seems like stinky doesn't love the idea
of people moseying
into his face without his permission
yeah he definitely
he's definitely not gonna like his fun
PayPal mafia
I heard when she told us
she had to write a disclaimer month later to not drink
real when wheeler
drops there are versions
of our bathwater
disclaimer please don't drink
this is not for consumption
Russian
prime more guns from your enemies cold
did the hands and give them to me
for science of course
bunk
oh we got the upgrades
on weapons to be
how much is it from even stronger
9k, 3, 2
things again rather expensive
look I don't want to drink that but
things getting cheekily expensive
bell delphine walk so wheeler can run
real Andrew
okay a little shake up need a bit
money although
they aren't really dropping much money
and
which is my
only
not concerned
but
it's definitely gonna take quite a few runs
I know that there's that like
bank area you know what excuse
you for shooting me
I'm just a innocent little thing
right reflin said there was a door up here
oh
there is a door up
oh it takes me straight to the villagers
hi
oh no hi villagers
give me your money
give me all your money right now
this is a stick up I have a cactus
and I'm not afraid to use it
I'm a donkey on edge
I'm a turnip on edge
oh it's like an assault rifle this time
as if that touched me
you're burping me burping
there's also a father friend
the face of turnip when he's shaking
I'm done
I wasn't paying attention
oh this doesn't have a limited ammo
I need to be careful
okay there is like a sleigh
which I'm quite happy
they can see me before I freaking
come on screen
they can see me
they can see me before I steal them
oh this is fucking
cheating
yes give me that
I don't even know
I think I'm going to need damage upgrades
before I start dealing with these folk over here
oh there's a hidden person here
what is it
it's like a gun for
of a frog
ow
I'm getting a bullet right there
hmm
turnip
come to thingy for an upgrade
yes yes yes
I'm just spraying
anyway a thought's blessed
now come
on stream
okay so I can
take two researchable items
back
I'm
these look exactly like the trees from
the legend of Zelda I said it
I said it right I'm not doing the boss fight
I'm too terrified but
we have been able to at least
explore this area quite a bit
how did you even get over there
I have no idea
I mean we could
okay
the noise this
oh no my money's full
right okay so the wallet is 2.5K
right take us home
I'm not going to use the
turn style thing because it's going to cost
me money but
we officially know that the max amount
of money we can carry is 2.5K
but that doesn't include like
trinkets that we can take back with us
there's another one
yes okay
our money is full so there's no point
we can take trinkets trinkets are different
they are calculated
differently
are you inking everywhere
is that the sound of you inking
get a complimentary bottle
of strony's bath water where every part
is
just shy 7K not bad
alright and then we're going to
in
research both of these weapons
about an assault rifle
he's getting cheeky
oh right
we don't want luck
I do think I want help though
weapons I can't really increase
I don't know what spilt milk is
but
maybe the gun one for
research
oh wait what was that thing
there's something here
oh no the bath
a lantern I don't know why we need
a lantern just yet
I got back from sailing
no idea it's such an easy thing to do
oh yeah you let the wind carry you
can't believe it you're not a real
sailor this is why I quit sailing
there's too many sweats
a lot of kill possibilities for marriage
but bath water is not something I don't want
oh you wouldn't
you wouldn't want cuttlefish
like soup base
how dare you
spilt milk
what happens when you drop the jar
oh that's why I'm going to drop the jar
what
I will take six bottles of strontis
exactly
I'm not sure what to invest in
or just keep my money and maybe
oh there's only one more health upgrade
and then that's it I'm done so
oh
hmm that's curious
maybe I can do the boss fight then
right fuck it we're going to do the boss fight
let's do the boss fight
whoa you got a death wish or something
oh I forgot to
pick up my weapons after dropping them
okay
okay okay okay okay
let's go do the boss fight in that thing up there
right we're just gonna
what is that bag of milk
is following me
help Canadians what are you doing
Canadians what's going on
right there are a lot of them
Canadians no
let's perish
no
Canadians it wasn't supposed to be like this
it was supposed to be different
I'm sorry I killed you because I suck at the game
okay
let's get going
oh my god that
ouch
I don't know if it's better to do melee against these bottles
okay
melee is definitely
better against these guys
okay okay
let's do it let's do it let's see what's going on in here
let me trauma dump on you
a bit turn it boy
oh it was good for nothing
freeloaders were giving me a hard time
we were here first they say
when I asked them to give me all their money
I decided to play nice guy
and throw a festival to win their favour
we were talking about
all sorts of interesting things myself
money my crown and achievements
then this junkie
oh you can't say that
the drug dependent vegetable
came in and well let's just say
we all made like
fat kids in leaf
what the only good
thing about you being here now is you can deal with it
well this chump is quite the stick
in the mud
alright you're awful at being tough
moving on even though
we're helping stinky here
we gotta get past this beast
all of the riches
must be behind them
break a leaf rookie
candy apple
I
hello hello
what am I supposed to do
how can I reach him
I'm too small
he must I
I